[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's weekly opinion editorials
show I'm Mike McCarty your host and I'm
Jake Decker and last week we worked on
an episode in which I had a lot of
criticisms about fortnight epics loot
fest free-to-play paid beta as it stands
right now and uh you know like kind of
expectedly so ruffled some feathers but
I was honest and I criticized it for a
few things namely epochs kind of sketchy
freezing for a lot of the stuff you know
a lot of the comments are saying why are
we judgements game it's only early
access right now and it's one thing when
you're paying like for pub gee you know
$20 for an early access game that they
tell you upfront it's in an early access
30 $30 for pub G they tell you upfront
it's early access on Steam and you know
what you're getting
same thing with dead cells which is
another one of my favorite games this
year and it's early access but they tell
you upfront and that was 20 I believe
and there they say it's early access
this is not a final game if you don't if
you haven't been following fortnight the
wording across 20 different places is
always different and if you go to Amazon
as I said in last week's episode of
reboot you will see four tonight on ps4
for $60 and it does not say I did some
serious digging around on the Amazon
page maybe they changed it now but it
never said anything about it being a
paid beta for an early access game that
will eventually go to free-to-play
none of those qualifiers were there it's
just gearbox itself who is helping out
epic distribute the physical versions
didn't say anything so that's a huge
problem and then the fact that you can
spend $150 and people are saying yeah
what gives you more loop on this game
when you buy it that the founders pack
it's that loot doesn't really matter as
it stands now until you're like 20 hours
in the game which I don't want to pay
that much money for a game that's gonna
take me 20 hours to get into and I feel
like some of the systems are in our
shadow but as always in our off week
episode we're gonna do a Q&A
Jake you haven't played for tonight much
but I do have some other questions for
you about early access and stuff but
I'll let you jump into the first
question from YouTube first one is from
Brent Brendon state he says as it stands
the fun doesn't last the game is
embarrassingly easy even even in the
late game thanks to microtransactions it
feels scummy and it shares the same
practices $0.99 mobile games it's just
another brain-dead grind fest IRA
spending money on it yeah so it does it
is really easy for a while and it
doesn't really explain a lot of its
systems and you know they're working on
that I mean again I know this is really
access and it could be better at launch
but I already spent a lot of money on
this game more than I usually do for
early access and again if I wasn't if I
didn't do this job or if I wasn't tuned
into fortnight after I got announced
seven years ago and didn't know what was
going on I might not have even known it
was gonna be free-to-play eventually
because this game unlike dead cells or
pub G is not all this game is already
designed to be free-to-play so that does
feels coming to me and I think epic had
similar messaging problems with Paragon
which i think is a much more polished
game and a lot of those things were all
cosmetics right it wasn't you couldn't
pay like twenty dollars to get better
loot llamas to get these rewards you
could otherwise spend ten hours getting
people that always said like he doesn't
understand that these are games are a
platform like destiny destiny was a full
game and a release whether you liked it
or not it wasn't you know it wasn't
designed to eventually be free-to-play
it never will be
be over the public the star wars MMO
they never initially were planning to
make it free-to-play they did that to
boost sales or to boost you know
interest later on so I do agree I think
a fortnight has some rip off scummy
issues with it right now as it stands
and I think if they were clearer about
it I might not has been it might not
have been as harsh but as fans they
weren't I don't know like did you know
much about fortnight going into it this
year like and what kind of model they
were gonna be doing no I I was pretty
excited for tonight when they first
announced it back in 2011 because from
what they said the premise sounded like
a open world minecraft game that focused
more on the combat aspects of Minecraft
I like it seemed like it would be a more
fun co-op action minecraft sort of style
game and that's kind of what it is now
except not really because everything you
build disappears after you're done with
that mission yeah I mean I didn't know
too much about it when it came out
Wow but yeah I don't know I we played we
came in the office like on a Sunday to
work and we played a little bit and I
think I was like now I'm gonna go back
to pub G yeah cuz I think I bought the
$80.00 version to give you a free code
so we can both play it and it's fun with
friends later on when it gets tougher
and you
actually do have to work with the way of
defense stuff like works must die but it
takes so long to get there and then even
then I would just rather upgrade weapons
leading up to that so I don't know it's
just a lot of shallow systems like game
mechanics aside some people haven't
found this game and that's great there
have been a few times when I'm like I
would like to go back and play with a
few my friends who are getting into it
cuz some of my friends really do like it
and they they like it for what it is but
they agreed with me as a lot of people
in the comments did that it was a little
bit shady and kind of foggy on how what
they were paying for at the time here's
one that actually kind of leads back
into what I was saying so aza Jabbar on
YouTube this is kind of long so you
might not be seeing all of it on screen
right now but it says it is hard to take
someone's opinion seriously when you
know he doesn't understand that the
issues he has with the game could be
fixed in the next patch morons like this
guy don't get the gun - yeah morons like
Mike mehar D don't get the concept of
games as a service and he is treating it
like an NES game that will ship and die
with bugs game journalism but very funny
sitcom indeed and then there was a
response earlier later down this thread
it is early access for a reason you have
the choice to not buy it like me and
wait for the full version that will be
free-to-play if everyone use that
mentality toward games that our game is
serviced then no one should play a
blizzard game and no one should play
anything free-to-play ever the industry
is evolving my dear you have the choice
either involved with it or stay the pass
and complain I think well I mean just
first thing right there is that you
touched on this earlier is that for
tonight was kind of advertised as a full
game not an early access game so I think
that is the issue if this was still
early access and they weren't trying to
sell physical full priced editions then
I think we'd be looking at this a little
bit differently yeah on our weekly live
show we talked about how a lot of games
like overwatch isn't that was never
designed upfront to be a free-to-play
game anything you can you can contribute
to crates but that's all cosmetic it's
not affecting the mechanics or the
systems of the game that's all uniform
for people that's not a free-to-play
game that's different for tonight itself
is already has free to play mechanics in
place despite the fact that it is not
free to play it you I you pay $40 for an
epic $60 you want a physical version on
Amazon through gearbox and they don't
tell you it's free-to-play or early
access or either of those
this isn't early access we're we're
paying for them to release a game that
is already gonna be free-to-play and
they're using the money to pump into
that to fix issues and then they're
gonna go to free-to-play that's
different than destiny
is a games at service and I agree that
is where a lot of the industry is going
but destiny was upfront about the fact
that no this is a full game you're
getting hours and hours worth and it's
what it say what you will about a
destiny that's mechanically that game is
like mechanically very good yeah we're
not huge destiny fans I didn't play a
lot of it that's different for tonight
itself was you know was you pay for
early access and then oh [ __ ] a lot of
the free place isn't Ferrari in place
they're just not actually completely the
game's not free but when we did play I
mean I was having fun like when we're
actually when I wasn't battling with the
UI when I wasn't trying to figure out
what the heck all these different
currencies are like what here I was like
who I'm gonna use to help me out and
it's like all like actually just playing
it was fun like I had fun killing
zombies and grabbing that sniper rifle
and building that little Hut but then
the issue was it's like alright we're
done and now that fort we made that was
pretty cool it's gone
ya know again to clarify I would
absolutely love for epoch to figure out
a lot of stuff for when the game goes
free-to-play in 2018 but that's never
gonna change the fact that as evidenced
by a ton of people in the comments on
this video not everybody knew exactly
what they were paying for and the fact
it was gonna be free-to-play and then it
was early access but it was also kind of
a beta epic needs to figure out this
messaging because this is harmful in a
way that games as a service was not at
all when we first were getting used to
the idea anyway but yeah I also do want
to point out the fact that titanfall 2
as a new wave defense mode speaking of
games that are good as games as a
service they've been updating the game
ever since it came out last year
frontier defense mode is awesome mean
feat watch any of our stuff you know how
much I love titanfall 2 that's a really
good way of defense if you're kind of
looking for that Orcs Must Die is still
good Unchained I think is the ps4
version that you can go play that's like
a third-person tower defense I mean I
grew up with Warcraft 3 tower defense
mods the winter Maul thaw 1.0 one mod I
believe to get really really deep into
it I played that a lot
I love wave defense I love minecraft I
don't love how any of those things are
implemented here in fortnight salty
shell of me
keep letting us know what you think a
fortnight if you're having fun that's
awesome let me know like some good
experience you had with it
recommend a few games thoughts that you
might want us to cover in the fall we
ought to get a bunch of suggestions I
have a whole list written out that
people want to see and like topics if
you have any ideas for future episodes
as always let us know we love your input
and yeah we'll be back next week as
always and if you want your question on
the show obviously you can leave a
comment in YouTube with your question or
you can always tweet it at us too that's
easier for us but we still go through
comments anyway so whatever is gonna
mean for you we always like getting
feedback yeah and Jake and I also stream
every Monday when possible at 11 a.m.
PST from GameSpot on twitch.tv slash
GameSpot or GameSpot's a YouTube live
streaming channel we've been playing
player unknowns battlegrounds for the
past few weeks we're gonna continue to
do that for another few weeks I believe
we're toss around the idea of
potentially doing a shadow of Mordor
like nemesis Forge run through to get a
nemesis ready for shadow 4 if that
sounds interesting to people maybe you
can join us for a few weeks and like get
to know our villains and the people that
are killing me over and over
Jake hasn't played that game all that
much and it's one of my favorite games
in last like 10 years so I'll probably
get him into it hopefully if you want to
join and help me convince him that it's
a dope game maybe we'll start that soon
but as always thanks for stopping by
we'll see you next week thank you for
watching
[Music]
you